seguimos abriendo de la decisión sobre
rusia y belarús para los juegos
paralímpicos de invierno que se van a
celebrar en beijing este viernes así es
ya hay una decisión respecto a este tema
después de muchos días de presión el
comité paralímpico internacional
permitió a rusia y belarús la
participación de sus delegaciones en los
juegos olímpicos de invierno de beijing
era una decisión casi esperada ante la
cercanía de estas justas que se
inauguran ya el viernes y comparte de
los equipos en territorio chino
rusia y belarús podrán competir con
bandera neutral pero esto es un añadido
a una delegación la de rusia que ya
estaba sancionada moscú ya iba a
competir en los juegos como el comité
olímpico de rusia como parte de esas
sanciones que se aplicaron frente al
escándalo del dopaje de estado
ahora tanto rusia como belarús irán a
beijing con la bandera paralímpica y no
aparecerán en el medallero los rusos
además tendrán que cubrir cualquier
símbolo de su comité que lleven en sus
prendas deportivas para dar más contexto
hwan actualizamos las sanciones contra
rusia y belarús en el mundo del deporte
sí porque desde ese martes una oleada de
organismos de federaciones han venido
siguiendo la directriz la recomendación
del comité olímpico internacional de no
invitar a estos países vamos a ver los
deportes cuyas federaciones han excluido
a los deportistas de estos países de sus
competiciones son el atletismo el
bádminton el baloncesto solamente a
rusia el biatlón en el ciclismo solo a
nivel de equipos el hockey sobre hielo
el pentatlón moderno el remo el rugby el
patinaje sobre hielo el surf es
solamente a rusia y el voleibol de otra
parte de algunas federaciones que
permiten a rusia belarús participar pero
bajo bandera neutral son la arquería la
gimnasia el automovilismo la natación el
tempo el taekwondo y el tenis en el caso
del tenis para la copa davis el hábil
jean cap si no habrá participación en
absoluto de russian y de belarús